hey boss man dude we need something cool
like right now Harry Potter's in the
trash and all we've got are these
DC movies no one wants to see
all right I've got a solution for you
what yeah just hold on hold on one
second oh
there you go who is that the Lord of the
Rings oh it looks terrible please help
me hey shut the up we can just
print some money with this token stuff
it's easy I don't know Amazon's doing
their own thing and no one really loved
The Hobbit movies I mean what can we
even make come on give us something just
let me die don't die when I tell you to
Aragorn stand alone he has a love
triangle and punches some Orcs I see I
guess Gandalf but he's young and has abs
young Gandalf beautiful beautiful one of
the most beloved franchises in history I
don't think we should be treating it
this way
foreign
but he's an Ice Road Trucker shut up